each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
great uh welcome I'd like to introduce
jakub corner who's here to talk about
LabVIEW graphical programming language
and interface from National Instruments
jakub and I went to graduate school oh I
don't know few hundred years ago long
time ago and it's good to see him again
he and his team David and Duncan are
here also from National Instruments and
they have they're going to be here all
day today and tomorrow morning so if
you'd like to meet with them to discuss
anything you see in the talk or things
that you'd like to discuss with them
other topics are interested please get
in touch with me and now I'll wait yeah
thank you Mike so i'll be talking about
labview but also be talking about
specifically about how we have
integrated time into the language and
the environment because it turns out the
time is a very important part of many of
our customers applications so so it's an
essential thing for us to integrate let
me first show a little bit about who we
are we consider ourselves to be leaders
in the computer based measurement and
automation and basically in doing
activities where customers need to bring
physical signals into a computer and do
something those physical signals we
belongs in 1976 we're based in austin
texas and we fairly worldwide covers now
with in terms of employees so one key
thing about what we do is that we have a
very integrated perspective on the role
of software and the role of hardware and
we really see that the it's a
combination of software and hardware
that makes our customers successful it
is not just software it's not just
harder parts but is the ability to put
these put up and suffer together in such
a way that they can they are able to
again take these physical signals and
bring them into the computer and do
something with them and that's what I
and an important part of that
interacting with the physical world is
the understanding of timing so I'll
basically base my my talk around the
concept of timing and see how it shows
up in LabVIEW and all this starting out
by motivating a little bit of timing and
then talk about how time actually plays
an essential role in taking measurements
and then out the bulk of the talk will
be on actually how we've integrated time
into the language and social in
different aspects how we've done that
and I'll end up with talking some on
some work we're doing on formal
verification of LabVIEW programs and
also about the timing of that all those
programs let me start with a motivating
example here this is kind of a stylized
picture of they love the Grace and
electric power grid and this is
basically where you get your power from
out here and this is an actual
measurement at the mailing mountain
station on august 10 15 96 and here we
can see the output from this in
megawatts here we can see how things are
oscillating and then this point yep we
have the blackout and I know many of you
were actually here in the and the west
coast at that time but this was a
significant outage estimated cost to
several billion dollars in actual cost
of the economy to recover from this
blackout here and the challenges of
course what can you do with this and so
this is this is data that was recorded
actual data from funded the problem was
how do you prevent this scenario from
happening you can see the good thing is
that there's actually some 70 to 80
seconds from the first instability
starts it being introduced here in the
power grid till the actual blackout
occurred so there's actually time to
make corrective measures here the
problem is what other matter what are
the corrective measures how do you do
that and we have a customer of ours was
actually working on on getting this if
solving the problem here so that the
system can be stabilized and the way
they're doing this is by having sensors
placed all around the grid to give input
to register the output at each of the
substations that are part of the grid
and then using GPS synchronization to to
align the measurements that are being
taken across the area so they can
actually be compared because if you
can't compare the measurements you can't
do any meaningful correction to because
you don't know where these you get a lot
of laughs that look like this graph you
laid on top of each other if you don't
know actually actually what's happening
at any point in time you can't can't
make corrective action so they're using
the GPS synchronization to take these
measurments bringing it into a central
site and then based on that they are
able to enjoy
act a stabilization back into the system
so to avoid this type of instabilities
in the system of course it's a very
complicated control problem but from our
perspective that the essence of the
measurement here is that these
measurements has to be synchronized and
this is of course over a very wide area
and this is why they are using GPS
position so this is just one example of
how timing plays a role in very concrete
way that and basically enables them to
build a stabilization system for the
power grid so these are some of the
things you have to consider when you're
looking at a measurement system you have
to think about how you're sampling what
kind of triggering that's going on for
instance in the GPS example they're
using the the pulse per second as the
triggering for their for the acquisition
so that that's that's how they get them
aligned you're looking at stimulus
response measurements and also these
global trekkers and Fox the
synchronization and then some movements
of data how you make the move the data
between the acquisition device on into
the computer and how the computer
actually gets notified that the data has
been coming and here are some here we
have a timescale of from nanoseconds
over two milliseconds of different
technologies that can that can be used
here and also we can kind of see they
shift from being purely hardware over to
software so we start off with some
backplane timing technologies that are
love you to get very precise in the sub
nanosecond range synchronization between
your devices and then you can get i/o
synchronization using a global clock you
can then start introducing software
program their PDAs where you kind of
going from the hardware into the
software and now we're going to go into
some time loops now explain those later
what they are in terms of programming
your applications with these timing
constructs and then going more and more
into the software world where you get
looser control if your timing but you
get more flexibility in your application
so these are some of the technologies
that are available and another way to
look at the timings is that this is some
of the technologies that we have
actually done for timing on the top side
we have a lot of hardware technologies
on the bottom we have a lot of software
technologies are available in the India
if that we've made available to our
customers I don't want you to read this
thing I'll point some of them out as we
go along I just want to point out this
is actually some things we've done over
the 30 years or so we've been in
business basically introduced in these
time
technologies as they become relevant and
available for customers but this is a
general a slide here on on some of this
area synchronization technologies that
are available so here we have the
precision of the synchronization going
all the way from picoseconds down to
seconds here and this is something about
the distance between the devices that
are available to you and the first class
of synchronization technologies are what
you call control signal based where you
have physical signals propagating
between the entities in your system so
may you may have actually on chip or
connections between pieces on your on
your device you may have backplanes this
is we have some technology called PX is
derived from the pci platform we also
have a bit early to go across multiple
chasity's and there's an interesting
line here coming down that's basically
the speed of light here the propagation
of a physical signals there's a limit to
how how far you can how fast you can
actually synchronize when you go over
distance and it turns out there's
another category here which is
time-based where you're exchanging
messages between the devices here so
you're no longer propagating a physical
signal but you're exchanging information
about what time it is and you're using
that to synchronize their clocks on
either end and there are some
technologies like prints of the gps or
eirick but also an emergent technology
called 1588 that allows you to get to
get highly precise a synchronization
over ethernet so there you can get into
the into the nano second synchronization
using SN recently technology but what
you're getting here is a time-based
you're getting synchronized clocks
you're not necessarily getting a
physical pulse train that is being being
being distributed between the devices
here's the example of one our customers
is bowing that is using some of these
synchronization technologies for
measuring the the noise that is being
emitted from different airplanes designs
and basically retrofits to this leaves a
737 that they're looking at the the
airframe noise and the inlet noise of
the aircraft and what they're doing is
they're flying this open air field and
they have eight what we call pxi Chaz's
we suggest computers that are
synchronized
and with each other so that these
measurements again can be correlated and
they are then hooked up to a very
integrated array of 448 microphones
arranged in a very special spiral
patterns basically capture the entire
sound from this over this white area i
believe is like 250 by 300 feet this
area right here that they're covering
and this is these are actual
measurements that they've taken about a
fun familiar aircraft is shell where the
hotspots Arthur noise and look at what
they could maybe do to optimize the
design so this is where they need
there's thai synchronization over some
distance to be able to again correlate
the the measurements from different
microphones and they're able to get
within one degree of precision between
measured means the to the aircraft so
this is a very typical example of what
our customers are doing but with it with
with timing on the hardware side to
basically get precise measurements well
then move into is talking about how we
can deal with time and concurrency in
the null software and I should going to
start with a quote from from one of you
guys and basically the concurrency
evolution is likely to be more
disruptive than the oil revolution and
this is something that we we've also
been aware of becoming very aware of and
something we actually feel that we have
have some very good answers for and I'll
show you that in a little bit and but
this leads me up to talking about the
primary thing that that I work on which
is the labview programming environment
so LabVIEW as a base is a graphical
programming dataflow programming
language we call it G just give it an
acronym it was amended one 1985 by one
of our co-founders and what it is is an
integrated program development
environment where with an editor
compiler link the debugger a
multi-platform bonds windows linux and
mac and multi processor architectures
but that is core it is a programming the
programming idea here is that there is
what we call a block diagram which is
this data flow visual representation of
your program in conjunction with a you
graphical user interface where you can
see
exactly what's going on in your
application so you can you can you can
put down these connections between
what's happening in your program and the
visual part of it and these two things
always come hand-in-hand they come as a
pair so you always have a graphical
interface to your to your programs you
can easily see your the output of you
day you can easily late your program for
unit testing and to basically see what's
going on and that's that's the the
graphical a part of the graphical aspect
is that it's not just a textual way of
program but actually is using graphics
for input and output as well as
programming it has a strong way of
integrating with Missy libraries we also
have active ways of integrating without
net assemblies as well and and at the
base of this is a large library of
signal processing which is really at the
core of our customers needs is to be
able to process these sequence that they
acquire from the real world by the way
if there's any questions here please ask
them that we can if there's anything you
want to cram oh absolutely that's right
and I should get to that a little bit as
well absolutely we sell let ya lap
here's a commercial project in good bite
is it should so this is that this look a
little bit more take a key graphical
programming language so it's it's a
homogeneous structured data flow model
and then it's a statically typed model
so let's look at a simple program here
these are kind of taking some pieces of
it but here we have three or four
constants and we have three adults
they're basically apps together these
values here and then in this this is a
connection to the front panel that will
show this value on the front panel the
graphical user interface of the program
so so this works by data flow basically
that each of these nodes will execute
when this data is available to it and
then produce an output so this node has
to wait for these two notes to to to
execute but the nice thing here is that
these two pluses here can execute in
parallel there is no order specified on
how they have to execute so and so
that's that's the base model of
computation here now what we add to that
is we
structure structures around this base
model of dataflow here that allow you to
do more things and I'll show you that in
a second here so here's next heir a very
well unknown a program you pls algorithm
for complete the greatest common divisor
and what I have here is the again a base
data flow graph inside a structure this
structure here is one called a while
loop and think of it very much like a
while loop in in any impurity
programming language it has a condition
which is this a stop symbol here when
that evaluates to true the loop will
stop iterating it is provided providing
some inputs over here and then once the
inputs are available it will start
evaluating the data flow graph on the
inside in this case it will take two
values in this is a little symbol that
it takes two values in which has the
maximum on the top and the bar and the
minimum on the bottom and then it
confused the the difference here with
this this perimeter right here and
compares the two values by quality here
and if they equal it will stop these
nodes here on the on the border are a
little special because they what they do
is they keep the state of the way of the
of the while loop meaning that when the
value comes here it is then propagated
over here to the next iteration of the
while loop so this is the only state
holding element in some sense of this
structure is this the shift register
right here and that allows us to prepare
state from iteration to iteration and
then once the stop condition evaluates
to true the value here it gets
propagated out and be put on the front
panel so this is a simple example of a
labview program that computes the
greatest common divisor it's just
written a little differently then then
then in their textual language any
questions on gcp
so as David mentioned here labview runs
on a whole bunch of platforms starting
off from the from the more standard pcs
but going into the real-time control
space as well where we have these more
industrialized ruggedized Paula formats
but also going into handhelds and fpgas
and even into the Lego Mindstorms
essentially you know I mean if you aware
of the Lego Mindstorm products but
that's actually alive you a programming
environment that is in this the user
interface is a little different on it
but but it is live you in this essence
so basically we're covering a wide
variety with one programming language
and one programming environment and one
of the things that the is is because of
this inherent parallelism that is easily
expressible in LabVIEW it is possible to
take a computation like this one here
and basically map each sub computation
onto multiple threads and then have them
run in parallel and before before the
result is actually being being a beam
returned and this has been inherent in
library since 1998 the ability to run on
multiple threads and run in parallel and
take advantage of multi-core and SNP
type systems here and the nice thing
here is that the user doesn't really
have to do anything in terms of being
explicit about this mapping here they
just have to write code and the data
data so dependencies will basically tell
the compiler licuado basically find the
dataflow dependencies in there and and
and schedule according to those okay so
the bulk of this talk is can be undone
timing how do you program the time here
because well I'm showing you now it's
just a data flow the pure data for model
of LabVIEW but what I've actually worked
on the nationís mint is trying to figure
out how to get time into it because
turns out the time and data flow are
very affordable of thermal concepts
where the data flow a model as I showed
you is purely about nodes that executes
when data is available to it but has no
concept at what time it needs to execute
so what we introduced some years ago now
is the time loop construct this is one
of those structures in LabVIEW that
allows you to organize a data flow graph
on
side but specify the timing of which
when this structure has to execute again
this is an orthogonal concept to the
dataflow meaning that that this is a
structure in library it will only
execute when all its inputs are
available according to data flow but we
put the further restriction on that it
has to obey the timing specification you
give to it and each iteration of the
tire of this loop also has to obey the
timing specification you give to it so
in this case here we say that every
thousand ticks of the underlying timing
source that is defined for this
structure this this loop should execute
and what you specify with it is where
does time come from and this turns out
to be something that's important for our
domain because it is not just time it's
not just milliseconds or ticks of a cpu
it can be the time that's coming out of
the actual physical environment that's
being being a measure of controlled
think of an engine for instance that is
a rotating engine where you have an
encoder that is telling you where the
the weather engine is rotational
position if you have 60 degrees all the
way around that is a in some sense you
can think of that as being a time base
that a program can run by and it once
needs to do certain things at it when
they Indian is a certain position and
that depends on the the speed of the
engine basically how fast it is rotating
in other words you can't correlate that
to a simple millisecond microsecond
timing because it is all dependent on
the rotational speed of the engine so
that's what you can specify out here you
can specify other sources of time
besides just inherent a computer time
that is relevant to the measurement
you're taking and you can then use that
to run your data flow graph based on
that timing and we actually have some
ways for you to overlay the two types of
timing domains so that you can use both
in your in your program if you if you
have applications there are four simple
examples in engine control where because
of spark plug were warm ups that you
have to do things that actually that the
warm-up actually takes a certain number
of microseconds but the rotation of the
engine is still determined by by this
encoder
signal that's coming in so you need both
both both elements of timing so what you
do here with this structure is you
program your time you say when this is
need to run and then while the structure
is running you can get a lot of
information about what is happening time
wise where as the structure is executing
here and as the timing source is
actually running and you can use that in
your program to adjust or report back on
on on the on the results of execution
and you can even use that to change how
it executes at one time so you can
dynamically update the execution of of
this structure at one time and then
finally when the when the structure has
finished executing you can get some
statistics out on how it actually
behaved well as running the idea here is
that to give the users an abstraction of
what they think of when they program
real time control systems this is a task
the idea if I have this task it has a
certain frequency needs to run at and I
need to record certain things about how
it's behaving I need to read my i/o at
certain points and I need and I need to
be able to output data at certain points
in time so time has now become an
essential part of a of the language by
giving you the bill to express behavior
over time in conjunction with the date
of though so any questions yeah yes that
that's what the easier do in some sense
now I mean you can you can do that on
this boundary here because this is when
the when the data for interfaces with
time is when this structure starts for
instance so here you can actually say
read the actual start you know exactly
when this was started to do because this
is all a when this is running a real
time system you may have specified that
this this has to start at time 100 but
it may be time maybe 120 when the action
starts running and at that point you now
get to get to know when it actually
started so you can make decisions based
on that yes that's also independent so
let me just take a simple a multi-plate
example here we have one loop that runs
every one milliseconds to take three
hundred microseconds to execute and
another loop that runs every 100
microseconds and takes 50 microseconds
to execute here so we basically have a
box of s here that are spaced
millisecond apart and we have these
pieces that are spaced 100 microseconds
apart here and the challenge is that if
you don't if you start running an a here
and will not allow a to yield you can
have all these peas be basically be late
so so if you're not basically if you
take a very naive approach to scheduling
this you and just say that the days till
the day's run then then you're not going
to be able to basically fit the piece in
vice versa if you just say peace will
have to run then the age will never a
really get to run because so what you
need to do is you need to be able to
interleave the execution of A's and B's
and the way you can do that is by using
the technique standard technique in real
time systems Paul wave on the scheduling
where the one with the the fastest rate
it gets the highest priority so you
basically this ap has to have a higher
priority than a and B will run whenever
whenever needs two and then able have to
yield and you end up an execution that
looks like this where you basically chop
the a up into little pieces that run
when the 8th when the B is not available
and we can see that both of them can
then fit into the timeline here and all
you need to do here is associate a
priority for a that's low one and a
priority for B and the way you specify
that in the time loop is just you your
basic the program you
asian rubies and you give them different
priorities so this is it this da that
has as the priority 100 in this is
probably 101 she explicitly state the
priority so this leads to one particular
way of scheduling based on priority here
and that's the one we've currently have
implemented here it doesn't mean that
the but so that's that's the day at the
core of it because it maps nicely on too
many of the real-time operating systems
including the ones we use this notion of
priority based schedule so so that's how
you realize that the example here with
the the two loops here and one of the
things we can extra visualize that this
is a this is a run this is what tool we
shipped with our real time system that
you can actually see what happened in
the system so here we have what's
happening in thread a time loop a and
here's what's how many times will be and
we can see that begets one first and
then a ones and then be ones and so on
so we can see that actually let graph
that I showed exactly what happens in
the real time system is running so this
is a very very nice tool for after the
fact looking in to see what happened in
the real time system in and and if you
have any anomalies to debug those
anomalies in the system so how does this
work here and this is a little a little
bit goofy but basically what we have is
we have a we have a schedule or sitting
in the middle here that decides based on
the different time resources remember
time is not just what's coming from a
cpu tick or from a time but it can also
be what comes from the data acquisition
device these kinds of signals that come
in it determines then what is the next
things that need to fire and then wake
up the different time loops depending on
on what is the next thing that needs to
a schedule and it actually has the
ability to schedule based on these
different timing sources simultaneously
then the latest thing we've introduced
is the ability to schedule these time
loops on on different ports because with
the advent of multi course we found that
the ability to run a real-time systems
on multiple courses is very very
important so here we have example where
we have a Time Protocol control loop
that you can assign to 14 and then you
can move the non time critical aspects
of your application over onto another
core so basically you get a separation
of the of the of the time critical
aspects and the basically devoted core
completely to your control aspects and
then move many of the normal priority
activities over on to the second point
and you do that by the explicit mapping
of the to the course you also have a way
for you to basically let the system try
to load balance things on the course but
that will not necessarily give you the
same determinism as you get here with
explicit mapping onto the course but
what we have here is actually running an
real-time systems on smps and with very
high performance results and one of the
so this is just a way wait for you to
visualize what's happening it gets a
little difficult when you have multiple
cores to see but but here we have I have
the ability to see both addictive in
both pores here we've highlighted what's
happening on one of the CPUs and the
other one kind of phase in the
background so you can hit me again debug
what's going on and here's the example
of our one of our customers using this
this is a at the Max Planck Institute in
Germany they're looking at building a
tokamak which is the one of these plasma
reactors and they basically using
magnetic force to keep the plasma in
place and Luigi unknown is one of the
scientists on this here and he could
very excited when he when he was able to
start using LabVIEW a real time for with
the with this SNP solution and I have to
take this a little bit plane itself but
he says well a view be obtained a 20x
processing speed up on an octa-core
processor really what this means is that
he actually with the one pole he
couldn't get to get the job done what
you're trying to do but then because he
was just too slow but once he got more a
multiple core system in he actually
started saying oh I can get this done I
know that can I get this done back and
do better and better and better and
that's actually where he got to the 20
20 20 times its own speed up the point
is that he was able to get to being able
to solve his control problem full of
plasma and this is this is a hard
control problem here it involves
multiplying very large matrices in real
time to do the control of the plasma and
that was the thing that he couldn't do
on a single core core system so so this
is this is example of how that's being
used any questions on multi-core
okay everyone in and talk about time
tracking so this is another tip so this
is the kind of third the thing about
time you want to talk about so this is a
time tracking network that we've
introduced some years ago for doing
deterministic communication of Ethernet
there's really nothing particular about
the networking technology but what it
does allow you to do is deterministic
the share data across the dedicated
Ethernet network among real time systems
and with the using software we're
getting about five microseconds
precision of the clocks on these devices
here and what you what you're doing or
this network is your scheduling all the
traffic that goes on between the between
the real time nodes so that is it is
determined ahead of time when these
communications have happening that's
very similar to a number of
off-the-shelf technologies like the ones
at the bottom here the way you do this
is by defining your network you set up
how what is the period of my network
this is given in microseconds here you
specify exactly when should the
different variables be transmitted so
here are some variables here that are
being transmitted across the network
between these real-time targets so in
this case here we're going to be looking
at a hardware in the loop simulation
I'll show you that in a second how it
works but you specify this this the
timeline and then you specify exactly
when these communications happen on the
network and what you get here is out of
that you get these timing sources this
game's best back to the time loop that I
talked about earlier this allows you now
to wake up your real-time activity you
real time loops when these things are
happening in this in the system so you
can actually specifically say i want the
loop to wake up at that point the
example we're going to look at is where
you have a model of an automobile or
motive engine and a model of the
electronic control unit for that engine
and you're going to be basically
communicating a different parameters
between these two models their rpms and
the throttle of the engine and then the
timing and a few fueling going back to
the model here so you're basically going
to have this these two entities
you give each other now you'll see in a
second why that's done over network so
you have these two models running here
because at some point you may actually
want to say rather than the just a model
of the ECU you may actually want to have
an ECU you in the process of building
remains you want to put that into your
system here the model of India doesn't
know any better it's still seeing seeing
something on the other side that looked
like an ECU controlling it but now
you're actually testing out this easy
you but you're testing it out against
the model instead of a real engine and
if there's any bugs and this you're not
going to have a crankshaft and camps
flying left and right because because
you're not controlling it corrected you
just seeing it in the model here that is
behaving out of whack so that's a very
common technique being used in in many
product designs is to use this idea of
hardware-in-the-loop simulation and
turns out that the network actually
provides in a very nice interface
between these these two components here
so here is a layout of how you can
communicate the variables between the
between this so we're going to get some
values coming out of the ECU and some
values coming out of the engine here be
communicated between the systems
absolutely they do this is this is the
programming tool they spent the layout
the network is statically schedule when
when they communicate they specify how
when this communication should repeat
they specify the time resources up here
when they want the different things to
be reversed for for the programming when
they want one of the loops 222 vtp woken
up and absolutely is it exactly it is
depending on how big the data chunks are
and it's basically calculating on some
some of the line speeds and network with
some padding on it so deep it can be
done let's automate on the others they
just say I want to transmit a variable
of this size in this case it's actually
just an array of doubles here question
you still you still have an interface
there that you that becomes a question
allow interface in the ECU with the
timing model you have have in there and
that's up to how the timing timing from
that issue how you're actually able to
interpret that in yourself in your
hardware components on that side and
that's that's still something that that
it depends a lot on how have you set up
how they can be done correctly yes yes
yes yeah yes that's what
it is not not is not just as easy as I
just put a bug but but but the but the
point is that you can do that that's a
mapping way of doing this okay so so the
way this is so that's how you specify
the node you start programming so here
you write a loop here that models the
engine so here we have when it gets a
value coming in from the base the time
resource that drives this loop is the
reception of the value from the ECU and
then it reads Sony situation will read
those values when you see you it will
run a step of the more engine model and
then set the values out to the engine
these are variables which is a concept
we use in LabVIEW to communicate either
between concurrently running loops all
right are between and distributed
applications so so basically I think I
have some animation that shows this so
the values here basically cross is so
this value that's being written here
will then be available and make
situation down here and vice versa so
here I data exactly an extra party are
not in on the same computer
you talk about this one here because
this this configures this loop to say is
the timing that is that once this loop
is based on on that you mm-hmm right so
that you mean you're saying this would
be blocking on that right but the thing
is that this is a loop it stayed in here
and just keeps keep iterating in here so
it's so that's that's how it so so this
is a looping structure you stay on the
inside basically until antillas know
it's going to wait wait until next one
to content
I'm you read this one but it is tightly
tied it is yeah you're right right that
is possible yes because here all you're
doing here is really reading a local
copy of that value you're not actually
waiting for anything to come in at that
point this these are non blocking reads
of local copies of these values it is
the fact that this gets traded that the
loop gets triggered on the arrival of
that that means that you have fresh data
available to you
simultaneously and I actually have I
have a slide on some some other ways of
representing similar things so there's
not exactly this abyss this application
here yes that's right and by the way
these are communicated in a you know
because of the networking they are
communicated with the fixed intervals
between them so it so it gives you that
pad on a time of repetitive time it is
not that these adjusted synchronously
arrived they arriving data it will be
very different if you did that based on
that ok and then of course the end you
can basically swap out the model from
the interface of realities you and of
course that is just a slight of hand
because I said there's much more to it
than that but but in the essence that's
all always to it to replacing it here
and what basically the design philosophy
is that you try and just in the
programming world they're trying to
abstract away a number of these very
intricate aspects of the hardware
architecture let's go back to the
diagram here this is fairly high
abstraction for programming time trigger
networking things with the distributed
real-time system here but the idea is
you're actually expressing the things
you care about you care about the rival
of data you care about reading the data
because that's a in essence what the
model needs but you're trying to
separate these these things out from the
more details of what
ticular hardware architecture you
running on what is exactly the data
transfer mechanism here and in many of
the aspect of the hardware software
boundary there's no notion of operating
system in that application there it is
just it is it is just plugged in and it
and this goes back to where our
customers are coming from many of our
customers are not computer scientists
they are in a scientist or mechanically
as aerospace engineers and they are not
very well versed inviting interrupt
service routine which could be another
way to do this on but it's just dropping
down to a completely different level of
abstraction the idea is to lift it up
here so they can work at these higher
level of extractions but still get the
performance they need so one of the
things I skipped over is that there's
this this is fairly high speed we can
actually do closely control loop around
5 kilohertz on an Ethernet network so in
a district fashion so I mean that it's
reasonable performance you get out of
this here for building systems for doing
at a high level of abstraction another
thing that they also this this
networking aspect gives you is temple
isolation we have some customers that
are basically and building different
aspects of of a system and they and and
and and well where each component is
delivered by a subcontractor and if
you're building a real-time system
that's one of the hardest thing to do by
contract because it not only do you need
to get your functionality but you also
need to get your timing right and if
you're building if you're building
around this model here of a time
triggered network each vendor can then
get its own allocate slot on the network
and if their system cannot meet the
deadlines they basically take that data
it doesn't get in time well it's very
easy to analyze and they cannot step
over the bounds of what of what the
other components is to end up avoiding
some of the finger-pointing that you
otherwise get if you trying to integrate
a real time system on a single machine
where by actually having this this rigid
separation by time and having the
network arbitrate the schedule for them
okay so the last a live view has been
all talk about here is the is the multi
hook the FPGA programming so we have a
module of LabVIEW that basically takes
the same type of diagrams that you write
and then compile them down on to run on
an fpga here
and this is a very powerful very an area
we're seeing a lot of growth and
interest in because again this is the
programming model but what it allows our
customers to do is now define a hardware
circuit that will in all case is always
talking to i/o that allows them begin to
bring the data into this fpga and do
their program that there are
transformations and the analysis of the
data in the inside the fpga and doing it
at the speed of the FP avis is very high
and doing it with the determinism and
the parallel isn't that's available in
the fda so here we have at these four
loops running on the FPGA and basically
you have as much parallelism as you have
Spacely space on the FPGA unlike with a
multi hall where you are fixed by the
number of course on your system so it's
a very very powerful io processing and
computing platform so these are some of
the examples of what our customers are
used one of the things for instance
they're doing a lot of stijl
communication protocols as a whole bunch
of these protocols we're different we're
signals are propagating along a serial
lines and where people have basically
have to extract the information in
certain way and these FPS turns out to
be very very efficient for processing
these these type of protocols and it's
very easy to write those applications in
LabVIEW but that's all I examples as
well and these are some of the platforms
this is probably the most interesting
one I think we have is a very very small
form-factor very ruggedized and platform
that has a real-time processor and
hanison FPGA on the back plane and then
has these different io modules you can
slide in and basically get the
measurement tight that you need to do in
your application you program there PGA
in the back plane to do the first order
of of signal analysis and signal
processing and then you can move the
data up to the real-time processes of a
further floating-point types of
operations on there and then you can
communicate data out three from that's
two up to a operator interface as well
if you need to do that but basically
they gives you a very very complete way
of programming a real-time systems for
that you can take advantage of the FPGA
and the real time process depending on
what you need to do and you get a lot of
flexibility and we're using this but we
also have other things that have more
plug-in boards for PCs as well that way
you can program the FPGA is where
again with I oh right bye-bye the FPGA
one example but it's being used is the
Large Hadron Collider at CERN here they
are using our fpga poor products for
controlling the beam in this experiment
under how many of you aware of this but
this is one of the largest instruments
that that's been built and and the beam
is about about this long about the width
of a hair but it has enough energy in it
to melt a ton of copper so it may so
basically controlling this this thing is
essential and and that's what they're
using the light beer PGA with motion
control to control to make sure the beam
stays in place or if the beam actually
goes astray we sometimes happens they
have a control way to divert it into a
tunnel and then basically have it hit
hit hit a big slab of concrete so I can
yes it does yes it's a 27 kilometers out
here and they're using some I think it
110 or so a state at basically stations
to a long the ring to control this beam
here so it's an extremely large of
course operation here and but they were
there basically and timing is everything
in this here that they have defined
control of each individual collimator
but also the synchronization that has to
happen because it's around this big ring
here and they have some very interesting
synchronization technologies that they
take advantage of there yes
unfortunately they're going live next
year and we don't try to help formal
verification yet but that's probably a
good segue to me to it I almost get
there to talk about that one of the
things that using on the FPGA is is a
variation of the time loop that is going
to call a single cycle loop which is
basically allows you to take a diagram
that's in here and run it within a
single cycle of the FPGA and basically
treating the data flow graph here in as
a combinatorial piece of logic that can
then run and run at that rate here so
it's a basic way for you to specify a
timing but at the level of the clock now
of the FPGA I'll just want to show that
click down here we have a this is our
continuous time simulation diagram that
all that works with simulated time
allows
22 to do continuous time simulation we
can actually also run in a mode where
you hook it up the right into a hardware
so you actually cooked into the hardware
timing as well if you want to do that
listen for the FPGA sorry you are
basically doing ok so this is a looping
structure right and it basically runs at
at the base frequency for that you
designate a for you can either be the 40
megahertz base clock that we have on
there it can actually be one of those
derived box that you have on there that
can be multiplied up up to 22 some some
top speed of it so am I really but you
can just sample the single and so the
complexity of what your the data you're
dealing with is just a single scalar
nine times out of ten when the phenomena
is occurring a lot faster than your
computing power you have to introduce
all of these different hardware
buffering schemes and buffered time
stamping
all the way up in your programming so
what this does is run your logic a lot
faster that's the basic okay so this is
what I was alluding to this is a this is
more futuristic so this is that another
perspective on well what do we really
mean about having time as a first class
citizen on the diagram well here's
actually an attempt of saying well let's
have wires that can carry time on the
diagram so these are special kind of
wise these a lot the wires that I've
showed you before in fact the only wires
are shown before are these little thin
ones down here the idea is that these
green wires here a bit ly carrying
timing way so this is coming from a
digital port on some on some board here
and are carrying physical pulses in here
into this frequency distribution device
that basically where you configured with
a sample rate and then it will produce a
pulse train that is according to this
sample rate here and it will then be
used to trigger this is an analog input
on ABC a block here that will basically
whenever a pulse comes in here it will
then read a physical value and put the
numeric value on this wire that can then
be accessed and do for control loop here
and similarly over here we have an
analog output that will then take when
it gets a pulse will output the latest
value that's seen here and sit send out
to the physical world so it's a way of
you to propagate these physical signals
may I specify how these physical signals
should be propagated and the timing
timing relationship between there's some
little subtleties here that this
actually happens on the rising edge of
that clock pulse here this happens on
the falling edge of this clock pulse
here the point here is that this is
being very explicit about the physical
signal set of flowing in your system and
these are concurrently running actors
all these nodes that are say that I
sitting here that are receiving these
signals almost like you're designing a
piece of hardware but it is done with an
abstraction that is about signals and
not about electric wires so this is one
way you could represent very explicitly
to timing in your application these
these wires don't have to just be
physical electrical pulses they could
also be things like time stamps that
could be floating down the wires as well
so there's a couple of different
variations of these here they can be
used
pending on the basically on what what
underlying technology available for you
this is very well to the five pgs
because here you are literally dealing
with these rising and falling edges on
wires but on a more compute based system
you may be more able to cut to cope with
timestamps flowing on wires so this is
some of the ideas where we're pursuing
in terms of being very explicit about
time being a first classes in our
diagram actually flowing on the wires of
the diagram okay last piece I'm going to
talk about me only be a few minutes for
this but basically there is formal
verification and this is something that
I've been doing with a met Kaufman down
at ut's computer science department he's
one of the authors of the ACL to therapy
on formally verifying like you programs
and what we basically seeing and I think
it's also come out of some of the things
I talked about is that as we are moving
into more and more these hardware and
control type problems people are
beginning to say well what about the
correctness of these things are built
what non building control system and the
will it actually will it actually do
what I think think you think it does
we're to seeing people gay and they are
getting FDA certification for some of
the the product of their products but
they're not quite sure about that have
we actually realized our specification
so we're beginning to get some some feel
for our customers saying we're asking
for this here and we think there's
actually something in life use graphical
nature that makes it amenable for for
for formal verification and I'll charge
us to show that in a little bit so am so
he has a very some very early sketches
of what we what we rapidly going to do
them this is going to be probably look a
lot different when we actually start
really getting into it something
customers can work with but it up here
we have a very simple library program
that takes this is a for loop that runs
a in times where in a surprise surprise
an input and then on each iteration it
takes the current count and ads as
that's word to this ship register here
that's initialized to zero and of course
you probably recognize this as basically
Gauss something of something of the
integers and now here we have a little
theorem block that basically specifies
the relationship between the inputs to
this
he's a program and the outputs of this
program here so think of this as being a
way of asserting pre and post conditions
of a program and so this is basically
saying that that if the input is
non-negative that implies that the
output is n times n minus 1 over 2 so
basically that's that's the way of
stating it but it's done in a graphical
way here so that's this is the statement
of the of the of the assertion in the
language what we've done is we've
implemented a lab you to list compile
I've to say this is a small subset of
lab you to list compiler basically takes
these diagrams and translates them into
a CL to code and which also has a nice
benefit of malvi actually having another
way of interpreting lagu programs within
within this environment here and one way
to think about ideally you want to say
that this is a this is a theorem you
would like to prove about your program
it may not always be possible to prove
of course this this theorem first of all
I may not even be a theorem of your
program second of all it may just be
hard to prove no matter what tool you're
using but another mode of this of course
is assertion basically you can leave
this in as an assertion you programs you
have the duality between between between
theorems of your program and assertions
that can be checked at one time but if
you can actually verify them then you
can remove those situations from your
code and for instance if you're dealing
with hardware vgh that means you get you
can free up some space on your on your
fbk if you actually if you don't have to
have the assertion as part of your
program anymore this has been our
project has gone through a couple of
stages here we started out not being
tied to a co2 is tightly where we
basically just use a co2 as a as a as a
tool we would ship some certain theorems
over to but we will keep all the logic
in our own little world but we will now
actually gone to a tool to a more deep
embedding into HDL to where we basically
translate the LabVIEW programs and the
assertions into a co2 formula and then
the ACL to reason about it and we
believe that a lot more leverage there
because there's a lot of a large body of
work in hl2 that we can actually take
advantage of for doing this and also we
can now do co-simulation between lab in
hl2 well because
nice thing about the party so too is it
is applicative so we can actually we can
run it as well so one of the things we
look so we're as I said we just started
the type of problems we're looking at
other are the kind of problems i showed
you some very very simple looping
structures but slowly getting any moolah
moving on with Max has basically being
honest about six with us for six months
now ever working as a contractor for us
and and and we're getting to the point
now where we can start looking at things
like state how to handle state in these
systems here and also handle if we're
going to start looking at at more
explicitly data types and how to model
the data types and again this is where
the ACL two libraries for handling
there's been a lot of work done in Asia
to community on handling data types in
different ways here and one of the
tricky part for us is handle I oh how do
you actually model e io and actually
prove properties of the IO one of the
things i do believe here is though is
that there are some aspects of the
graphical representation of lacquer that
makes it easier for end-users to take
advantage of theorem proving because you
actually have ways with graphics to
overlay assertions and overlay the proof
structure on top of the diagram as
opposed to in a textual thing we have to
kind of interleave it together in a late
more linear fashion so I think there are
some things here where we can actually
can help people do it for instance how
do you frame the invariant properties of
a while loop but you can actually expand
the graphics of the while loop and an
overlay it with with the aspects that
you need to provide in order to prove
your while loop but still have an aspect
that is just the base program and
basically have had the views of these
things of the two things I'm skip over
this year we had last thing I want to
talk about is of course tying it back to
the timing is that one of the things we
like to do is we like to prove a
property timing properties so this is a
very simple example of an FPGA tie
program where you have a digital signal
coming in you have some computation
taking place you have digital signal
going out here and you like to be able
to say something like when the when the
when when the the line here goes high
and the clock has a certain valve
you well then you get to a point where
the digital outline goes low and the
clock has progressed no more than five
ticks from that point on onwards and so
you that's the linear way of basically
stating what's written here in this
little block right here so we like to be
able to prove properties like this of
the program of course this need you
don't to be able to do they shun each
our models of how the fpga fabric
actually evaluates this this chips well
how does how this time what's the model
of the time so you can actually
understand the progression of time but
again for your PDAs that's fairly well
understood because and there's actually
tools that will help you extract that
information for you so that's basically
the end of my talk and so it's a lot
about basically different ways of how
we've used for timing into our language
and going all away from from the from
the lego mindstorms all the way up to
the lodge Collider thank you any
question that's a good question and we
we made it just a decision that that we
seemed as you think there's more of
course ideally you want to do both your
deal you want to have a completely
validates tag all the way down but but
there's there's other ways to get to
assert that the compiler does the
correct thing whereas the end users may
need some may need help actually be able
to state the correctness of the program
in fact I've strong belief that just by
writing the assertions of the programs
they actually will think more about what
they've written in actually and probably
get a eliminate a number of bugs just by
writing down those assertions the next
state is actually not even verifying
them but just running those assertions
as part of the program third level is
actually going going through and really
verifying it and then learning can again
even deeper insight into what they wrote
and well or not it actually fits with
the specification
testing testing testing testing you
that's a and it's it's a question being
realistic it's the compiler is a very
complicated complicated thing and
no you won't that depends that it is up
to the user to determine what what is
what is that what is my error error
handling here it is this a catastrophic
shoot I shut down the system what should
i do at that point
timing i see the flexible in that you
get but i'm trying to figure out is for
example what do you consider your basic
law of computation against what you
would verify and so going back to the
previous question you mentioned alright
so so so so so there's a couple of
aspects to that there is the model of
computation is independent of timing
timing is a separate dimension to the
tutelage that you have to add which is
platform specific because it has to do
is very different timing when you
running on the pga even from 10 feet eh
is another pga but also between the real
time control on fpga so there's
something where architecture will come
up and actually it casts a shadow and
you have to bring that into your
verification test these tix are
different depending on the architecture
and it is will be part of us to model
that so you can faithfully verify
against it otherwise you can't verify
that the timing properties
okay so how do we create a synchronous
the one trick that would be what I asked
if you can check the value of time and
make a choice mm-hmm how do you know
yeah I'm not sure tell you i do right
absolutely tonight and I think we
basically always
problems but also introduced a huge
amount of non correctness in terms of
formal recruiting so if you leave
yourself narrowly constrained or
formally provable whistling said a model
competition in my opinion you wound up
solving not very many problems and so
you have to pragmatically balance how
many problems can i solve my cell phone
on formalism the purse is formally being
correct and solidarity so we're trying
to strike a balance I think the very
point teenagers will probably come up
with really good representations of
asynchronous systems based systems we
have a little corners where maybe
function
that's a good question so that this is
where this is where some of the
dependent of course depends on on the
infrastructure but this is where some of
these synchronization technologies like
1588 and DPS Cygnus is basically can
inject the correct notion of times are
you so everybody has a common notion of
time because if you don't have that that
was always back to the power find it
exciting example i shortened by the
beginning if these things are not
correlated you can't make sense of you
can't do any analysis on it these are
just grass and they show something but
if you don't have that common sense and
that's exactly the sense that this is
where something like 1588 is a very
powerful technology that allows you to
distribute a very precise clock in your
system well I mean so the best
approximation is your time Stan but when
you can in using common common time so
they said once it gets into the
perimeter of where you know where your
comment I'm basis you start time time
stamping it all you purely just
basically when you see it that's when
you think that that's that that's what
that's the times have you have it's not
very good but it is limited by that i
mean there's coordinator watches and go
okay we're on the same time now now
we're going to act
with industrial automation systems that
basically build stuff here ice cream
whatever they timestamp very
coarse-grained uncorrelated more or less
I'm going to make my best approximation
of what the current wall clock time is a
globally accepted time that will
propagate as a data value somewhere no
they're looking at we'd all have been
close enough and as long as the process
itself is slow that's accurate no it all
depends it all depends on time scale
you're looking at
thank you will my PS done right
thank you much